aloha reject nation guru Gelber here I
have finished season two of attack on
Titan you've heard us mentioned many
times that we do TV show react should
watch along this meaning we have one of
those things you've seen other youtubers
do a lot of patron pages do it now to
where you have a time code and then you
could seek it to watch along with us one
of the shows recovers attack on time and
so yes we cover by hero academia
supernatural Gotham Riverdale Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood John does music
video coverage we also do weekly Q&A a
shameless plug but anyway after
finishing season two I saved this one
reaction it was episode six of season
two because I was like you know what I
feel like this is gonna be my favorite
episode of attack on Titan and sure I
have to fish in season two I still think
it is because it just had so much shock
value to me I loved it
I loved this episode I'm gonna start
season 3 sometime this week actually
yeah I was like you know what the TV
show reaction watch alongs are on our
patreon but I wanted to share this
specific way here on YouTube so I hope
you guys enjoy what's going on patronage
X it is Sunday night right now and I
decided you know what
normally on Mondays that's when we have
the Gotham reactions go up or whatever
but I was like I really want to continue
attack on Titan first so I'm just gonna
hop right to that anyhow let us begin
I'll blast the audio for you know the
beginning parts of the show so it's
easier for you guys to sync because I
know people watch for multiple streaming
services i watch this from amazon which
has a different intro so it throws off
people who watch from crunchyroll and
all that but let's get to it shall we
hit in play 3 4 5 6 7
now there's 14 15 16 17 18 19
so excited to watch
mission moment
I hope we get more error now no missing
my boy Aaron
all right for you guys who recently
joined I have
[Music]
I have a bunch of questions that I write
down for the season because I've been a
little confused here there's a lot of
questions that have been raised
oh I go to class this went off what's
with Krista and Ymir I know their
history now who is you Mir I think I
cross that off I have a better idea who
was the beast Titan why did that Titan
talk to Connie what is with the priest
and knowing about the Titans in the
walls how come we're now six episodes in
and barely caught up with our main
characters who is historia why doesn't
crunchyroll work properly for me if God
is real and heaven Israel why did he
make us here first
how come it's been more than a year
since I competed on this Schmo down do I
prefer my hair to be slicked back or
puffy and curly that's my girlfriend
prefer that way these are all questions
that attack on Titan it has been raising
I think that's the first time I'm
noticing all those different like the
evolution of animals and stuff there you
know you see like the lizards and all
that I should have paid closer attention
to her because they like I saw some
images I haven't seen before
warrior great Tom Hardy movie
wouldn't a con time 5 min the rain
that'd be dope I love this show sorry if
I talk too much I just really love this
[ __ ] the guys looking at the camera
but she should heal so she's alive
right I can't take that chance
it's quieter she's ever looked
obviously
it's happening to Annie
no family history of rice noble family
okay all right which I remember that
steam
yeah did anyone mention that the beast
heightened yet to these guys do you know
about doing about the beast-type
beast-type time over a wall and
everything you know yeah pathetic the
word
the point is you oh yeah that's right I
remember that moment that was like a
badass moment
in terms of what
the war is not over guys dude the fact
that you survived is Surgenor great
[ __ ] so listen man
so happy we're all they're all back here
just you Connie you got it all yourself
edge of the Ritz a commercial break
there okay
where the inverse so the pupil he must
must be a Moultonborough
that evolving whoa what an accusation
the mysteries building
- that's scary man - humans must be
evolving into them I'm in love with you
it's another probability I'm the armor
tag he's a colossus
what the [ __ ] going on my chills just
whoa it's time truth there's like giving
an example of like what the [ __ ] is
Kevin Hart
breathe Oh bad sip doesn't get the door
when they cut back like a past person
hey it was just asked about
[Music]
how fascinating this is so much
information how I stand
this so I let's just line up with the
show
it's a great memory dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
so much
I thought I was just gonna watch like
another cool episode of attack this is
so crazy
whoa what a shot
I feel like I'm having an anxiety attack
rude
Oh
cannot be happening
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
like I am overwhelmed like a
[ __ ]
whoa that was a [ __ ] uh gonna do this
patreon lens thing so some of you guys
told me this next episode of attack on
Titan is crazy
talk about under [ __ ] selling it holy
[ __ ] whoa I don't I don't even know I
don't even know where to begin I thought
I was just gonna learn some [ __ ] about
who historia is I already forgot her
last name okay
review this episode you've commandeered
that twist that reveal there was a point
in there when there when they were
talking about it and like he's saying is
a colossal tide and I love how they
started revealing it because all the
soldiers are walking away errands just
chatting and it just sounds like
background chatter and at first I
thought Reiner was just talking in a
fashion of you know let's try to get
inside the Titans head didn't know why
he was doing that and then as the
information was going wait a minute it
doesn't sound like he's doing that as
the information started unfolding my
thought process was going this is some
weird twist that the writers must have
just included at the last minute and
they started doing all these flashbacks
and [ __ ] you're like that's that's some
good [ __ ] riding right there man that
is good [ __ ] riding I've been
surprised before I've been shocked and
there's been reveals and twists and
whatever that have I've been like but
none more impressive than
that I I have not experienced something
where I'm like they were little trinkets
I didn't every guess that he was the
colossal Titan or whatever but it also
her making sense I we broke out of the
hand how I was able even to have the
strength to pick up that one Titan even
though he's in human form have the
strength to do that and the more
information is being revealed about all
these humans who are secretly titans as
well and then Reiner talking about his
hometown and wanting to go back it's
just making me go how much bigger is
this world how much bigger is does this
mythology go him wanting to take Aaron
back with them is [ __ ] gnarly because
it seems like every other human that is
also a Titan is kind of in on the
[ __ ] joke here who's kind of in on
what's really going on because they all
seem to have an understanding of their
abilities they all seem to have an
understanding of their roots and their
ability whereas Aaron he this all seems
so brand-new for him when he was
morphing out into it's a Titan form he
was calling them traitors because he is
all for a humanity side where it seems
like everyone else is a spy of some
sorts and it seems like some of them
have been conflicted over this journey
because it's been Titans Inhumans
versing one another and from what I
gather from this information is that
these Titans who are in human disguise
or just staying human I don't know the
proper terminology for the [ __ ] that
some of them like maybe Amir that once
they get to know the humans they you
know they start to feel a compassion and
a bonding with them that Kaycee seen a
lot of like spy mafia movies where they
go undercover but they start to really
sympathize for the people they start to
really sympathize for some of the
gangsters
it's kind of what's happening here I
think with some of these people who stay
undercover so long as a cadet as a
soldier whatever military police and
then eventually they start to become
real friends with a lot of these people
you know like a lot of these twists in
becoming a fan oh there were secretly
Titans but to know the colossal Titans
whoa and from a structure riding level
like toying with the environment of how
you know it's a dark and stormy night
and then the weather starts to get a lot
more rainy and windy
before Reiner morphs out in a Titan form
and that's suspense that tension you
know sometimes there's what this show
will do with this structure is have a
plot reveal then they'll go like okay
earlier 12 hours or like how they do
here and then they start to divulge is
information that's coming out and I like
the approach of how Aaron is just tell
them about a [ __ ] tide and he's like
no kip yeah that's [ __ ] won't
believe it Ryder no come on it's like
this dude just keeps getting heartbroken
that level of mystery and build-up and
then there's that hot second where
rhinos like you know starting to lose
his [ __ ] before he morphs adding you're
thinking maybe maybe Ryder is just going
crazy you're kind of hoping what Aaron's
hoping like maybe Renner is just a
little delusional right now but sure
enough he's not and Mikasa trying to
like [ __ ] them up and take them out
before they they have a chance to morph
out all the soldiers trying to get air
in a way Aaron really is the secret
weapon because he seems like he's the
only human /title without a hidden
agenda here
other than to help humans win the battle
but now there's even more questions I
got to add to my list like what's been
the real mission here all along what's
this hometown they're talking about how
many more [ __ ] people are actually
Titans god damn what an episode it's
whoa that that really [ __ ] got to me
I love this show
alright guys well thanks for watching
[Music]
[Laughter]
direction animation all that like I love
their visual storytelling that one shot
where I can remember his name right now
that the guy who's not Reiner where's
that he's just like slowly moving behind
overwhelm my thoughts are not concise
are not coming out in articulate format
this is when reaction videos are [ __ ]
awesome you get like this thank you guys
for watching thanks for underselling
just how intense this was gonna be I
love this this was this is amazing thank
you